yeah welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game against some scary opponent
the Rivermont stop playing if Roy let's
let's play as a sodium and see what line
he opts for not i'm not positive what
what opens is silly and i would go for
if you place neither three but this is
obsolete already is going for c3 maybe i
can irritate them with g6 the idea being
after capture to play d 5 all right the
subtree 7 and after d 4 i'm going to
take and play d5
if he takes now I play Knight f6 and try
to get the porn back some typical
structure form Carol can't panel
actually but okay it didn't it didn't
happen huh so here Bishop g4 yeah I
guess try to get rid of them notoriously
problematic bishop on c 8 so just
capture me out come on let's get rid of
this piece and it's not clear that the
queen is so great on f3 I I assume that
is going to take what the Queen G takes
is a very questionable structure
sometimes you have dynamic ideas but
probably not here okay now my idea is
just 96 97 95 and win the d4 pawn in an
ideal world i hope i win this check yeah
here here the question is the question
is should i play knight c6 mmm it's not
bad the things he can we can take and
this pawn on the C file might be an
issue maybe just play here it's not it's
not a problem I can play a 6 get rid of
the pin and play 1976 it's not as good
as set up as I minute as I am described
before but it's not not a bad one we
have play Knight is seven years Bishop
g5 hmm
not a bit irritating
but anyway what else cannot really play
without 97 okay um what should why do
probably just Bishop d3 Bishop a form I
don't really um see a point and a I
certainly don't want to give up your
Bishop this would surprise me if this
was any good the shutdown maybe maybe
you can maybe take and play look like
blue 3 b3 Bishop e3 okay so 97 now he
can't play Bishop g5 irritating but what
else I mean I need to get this night out
of g8 and prepare prepare castles okay
he doesn't really doesn't really think
about that too much k right here and
then let's see probably just castles and
turn
question is should i play on f6 at some
point f6 trying to get to the d4 pawn
like castles f6 takes Queen takes and
everything points to deform maybe
another idea is to take and play d4 I
mean night d takes a five takes default
setting up a pity this could be a good
idea but I certainly need to castle for
that so first I castled
yeah if it was my move that actually 90
takes d5 and d4 would be a very valid
idea probably a very valid as it it's
just good yeah just a good move night d
takes d5 let's say if he plays nothing
moves yeah this is not a nothing move
and a good one could move problem so
yeah let's just improve here but not
spent ages on the clock after takes now
takes d4 he would have been able to move
the bishop and then set up a pin on the
default so Ruby one was defending
against this the sacrifice rook c8 is
just a general improvement and it also
allows after night um night a four to
play b5 aha Queen age three yeah it's
playing some interesting moves actually
just just for instance let's say add a
blimp queen bee 6ef not just for example
it's got 95 ed Queen d7 the screen on h3
is setting up some sort of x-ray on the
night and it maybe maybe prepares Bishop
h6 at some point and also after f5 takes
and has an looks at the e6 bond yeah
this is an interesting move Queen a tree
anyway anyway anyway yeah let's go here
night be four nights e-form it's still
I'm just it's just a kind of a French
structure value of use your nights to
try to provoke weaknesses here the only
thing really differing from French is
that
I have this Bishop on g7 ng6 play but
even that sometimes happens in the
French it shows up the the kingside
maybe maybe Korean age 3 also intended f
ing for hmm yeah why not actually a
possible
they are not before night c4s my idea
let's see what he's coming up with moves
like f 4g 4g for they are possible but
the nights are really quick here with
getting I'm counter threats on the
queenside Queen actually was interesting
but the the offside the the downside of
this move is of course that the queen is
very far away from the from the Queen
side let's say Queenie to as an
alternative move would be just nearer
and nearer the Queen side ok some nights
euphoria yeah nights you form that's
good attacking the pawn on b2 and
intending to at the right moment to take
on e3 I know this is not a great bishop
but sometimes taking it as a good idea
anyway as you get play on the dark
squares especially am oh he's giving
away be too surprisingly yeah it doesn't
really have any attack him I think ok
let's take me to no need to to think
about this too long it's getting this
pawn destroying the queenside structure
and he doesn't really have a great reply
I mean luke t two runs right until night
c4 back and Aoki one I don't know looks
pretty pointless
yeah I think he needed to to play on
some sort of defensive move not one
hundred percent sure what move exactly
but alright so maybe look look d3 night
before it's really am difficult to to
set up any concrete threats IAM for
black f white I mean for white to get
anything against my my king it's
difficult okay watch now Queen Queen B 6
mm yeah or b-five just be five
I also wonder about f5 let's say f5 he
takes Queen takes I'm attacking d 4 + f2
yeah I come on I like that it's um it's
immediately getting at the default porn
as well and if he doesn't take a must
take I really if he doesn't take I just
closed up the Queen at the kingside
completely and he's got absolutely no
play then I can if you place a slow move
I just play be five will be 6 and so on
now he needs to take Queen takes was my
idea or wait just some better no don't
think so yeah now d for as a checked f2
is a check
yeah okay he six is a weakness but I can
easily cover it but through key age and
I got concrete player d 4 + f2 you know
here here it's actually a question like
I could consider to take F too but I
don't want them just just go here to
keep this threats in the position on d 4
+ f2 how to how to defend now I think I
can just take g for next booth
he doesn't really have a great defense
move I for f2 as well Queen g3 mini and
then I can take the form
yeah those pieces on c3 and b1 don't
really help much
quite resigned yeah a bit bit early I
mean it's lost but usually a.m. there's
some some more fight in those lost
positions but I'm also five minutes up
on the clock it's difficult to even play
move because all those pieces this piece
is on d4 and see for us so I'm so
dominating for some reason i cannot i
know i can think those pieces are so
dominating I think he needs to really
play some some defensive luthien before
exactly in this position he needs to he
needs to improve here I think it should
be a best equal for black maybe even be
three just um just covering the
sensitive square night c4 is really a
move that you need to attend to and here
um yeah okay you weaken those but still
probably the way to go I can I can play
a strengthening move or try to be more
concrete but this looks good yeah
connecting rooks maybe I get this in
night here I think it's about equal the
computer on vm is giving white a slight
advantage 0.4 may be due to the bishops
I don't know but black is very very
solid I mean if you look at this it's
it's a perfect structure with all on
white squares and the dark squared
bishop so very healthy and you only have
this space space disadvantage in the
center of K this is a big issue but it's
a it's a very young very solid position
to have it's entirely different if what
if there would be a nite salon the ball
in the bishop on d 7
for example so on this is very healthy
for black and probably not much more
than a symbolic advantage but ok he
needed to really attend to um to this 94
idea after night c4 here it gets tricky
to not even lose use material if he
plays be three I can take and gap this
is this is quite comfortable already for
example after Queen takes I can be again
consider this move and just just have a
look at at this kind of structure
remember when I said that taking the
bishop the bishop only three can be a
good idea this is one of those cases
because I have a look at the dark
squares get very very exposed this is of
course an extreme case here black is
just winning Hayden Bishop age six is so
powerful so after this he needs to take
here but also not great now yeah he
needs to play b3 really I wasn't so
aware of that in during the game
actually that this is basically the only
move okay what he played was maybe still
um not losing or something but how do
you protect this now probably here very
ugly booth but it's keeping things
together after this it's basically
losing it's not just the pond the
problem is that this pond won't be too
is the the anchor for the knight on c3
you you lose the whole Queen side or the
whole queenside structure gets a gets
blown to pieces alright thanks for
watching